one of the big big hits of this whole
pandemic you know when the history is
written what did everyone do everyone
apparently watched Tiger King and Joe
exotic you were there first I knew him
before he was famous and spent really
the best part of a week with him for a
documentary I did in 2011 called
America's most dangerous pets and he was
back then as he is now well now he's
behind bars spoiler alert you're
supposed to say spoiler alert before the
spoiler apologies I can redo that but
the he was he was still running a zoo
and he had I think 150 Tigers and he
back then he also had two husbands but
they would one of the husbands was the
same and another of the husband's was a
different husband and if I have any
regrets is that I didn't talk to him
more about that the only thing he said
about that at the time was that it was
along the lines that where else bars
love me you didn't use the term love
makes it you said something like well
when we're gonna get it on it either
it's either all of us involved or it
doesn't happen like he basically had a
rules of engagement for three-person
lovemaking Wow
[Music]
you